il écrit sur le système de la santé la
mort sur la médecine elle même cette
fois le docteur alain vadeboncoeur
il est invité d'honneur au salon du
livre de montréal
il est avec nous ce matin de terre votre
bon coeur bonjour bonjour félicitations
invité d'honneur au salon du livre
ouais je dis qu on me fait l'honneur de
m'inviter en fait j'ai dit à dany
laferrière que j'étais aussi à l'aise
dans ce milieu que lui peut-être s'y
était à l'urgence en train de travailler
donc mais c'est un plaisir puisque un
honneur de voir ça comme ça parce que
vous écrivez également sur votre site
internet que vous n'êtes pas un écrivain
en fait non j'écris je me que j'ai
commis quelques livres et mais bon mon
métier principal ses médecins que en
fait j'écris beaucoup sur la médecine du
si c'est bon c'est mon sujet
d'inspiration on pourrait dire puis
l'écriture c'est moi bien je dirais
c'est pas plaisir je le fais vous avez
écrit beaucoup de livres plus critiques
que sont la santé privés de soins des
ordonnances et cette fois ci on change
de ton complètement plus on voit la
photo authentique c'est vous photo non
retouchée avec absolument que c'est ma
photo de graduation en médecine qui
avait fait d'ailleurs à certains
scandales on pourrait dire à l'époque
parce que des collègues qui appréciait
pas tellement qu'on attaque l'image du
médecin comme ça on le savait et mais
l'explication du pourquoi une chance du
geste allait d'ailleurs ab je peux pas
raconter mais c'est un geste politique
c'était une prise de position pourrait
dire d'accord d'accord pour répétition
malade on change de temps c'est un
recueil d'histoires plutôt cocasse qu'on
retrouve à l'hôpital dans les salles
d'urgence des histoires vraies
essentiellement et moi j'ai écrit un
livre assez assez sombre sur la mort
assez intense et là c'est plutôt un
appel inverse ça peut être on peut
parler d'histoires drôles mais c'est
surtout des histoires et des fois un peu
étranges ou cocasses quand rencontre si
c'est des choses qui me sont arrivées
essentiellement des histoires qu'on me
raconter et que j'ai recréé en changer
un petit peu les voix des personnages
les les genres tout ça pour pas que les
gens se reconnaissent mais en fait c'est
pour montrer plus que c'est le théâtre
de l'urgence où on voit de tout et il ya
de l'étonnement de tous les côtés a fait
et où des fois en fait on s'amuse
puisque les gens pensent en poésie à oui
c'est ça
amené dans un endroit où qu'on ne voit
pas finalement tant que patient parce
que quand on y va
c'est dans un tout autre état d'esprit
absolument c'est l'envers du décor pour
réduire mais je vous dirais que l'humour
même avec les patients j'utilise assez
souvent clinique mais déjà ces malades
parce que ça va être des fois à
dédramatiser les choses et donc c'est
pas ça ces milieux qui comme n'importe
quel milieu de travail a de tout mais
c'est sûr qu'on vit des émotions parfois
extrêmement intense des fois c'est plus
léger comme comme partout on dit que
c'est un livre à lire entre autres dans
les salles d'attentes à l'urgence d'un
oui puisqu'on attend parfois
ben oui beaucoup mais là semble-t-il de
moins en moins en tout cas c'est la
volonté de la connaissance venir québec
de diminuer le temps d'attenté à
l'urgence à 90 minutes
effectuez vous est-ce que c'est réaliste
comme objectif mais en fait tout
objectif est réaliste ça dépend des
moyens qu'on se donne ce n'est pas du
contexte dans lequel on pratique il ya
des raisons pourquoi il ya de l'attenté
à l'urgence au québec en particulier ça
ça c'est lié beaucoup au nombre de
médecins scellier beaucoup à
l'utilisation de gens s'y est beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui vont à l'urgence
plus qu'ailleurs
et donc si on réussit à transformer sa
par exemple en améliorant la première
ligne en augmentant l'accessibilité à
l'hospitalisation
ça peut arriver le problème c'est que
c'est des changements majeurs et c'est
sûr que tous les gouvernements se sont
butés à ça depuis 25 ans il ya une
certaine amélioration de la dernière
année mais il reste que c'est difficile
donc c'est possible mais ça dépend de ce
qu'on met comme moyen pour y arriver
donc c'est possible mais il faut des
changements majeurs des changements de
fond parce que c'est pas pour rien qu'il
ya beaucoup de temps dans les urgences
au québec beaucoup de gens sur civière
c'est parce que le système est un peu
bâti comme ça donc pour des bâtir un
système pour le reconstruire
différemment c'est ce qu'il dit cette
semaine dans l'actualité en santé et à
ottawa qui a promis de sévir si québec
ne remboursait pas les prix les tarifs
au privé parce qu'il ya des patients
bien sûr qu'ils vont priver pour aller
plus vite
vous êtes un défenseur du régime public
vous en pensez quoi en effet le débat
sur les compétences
québec ottawa ce que si c'est le bon
débat à faire sur la question en fait
ottawa souvent était un défenseur du
système public
historiquement surtout pas quand les
promesses commencèrent à faire plus
d'examens privé c'est arrivé à quelques
reprises dans l'histoire c'est arrivé
les frais que ce soit lent
donnez donc il ya forcément plus ni
moins le québec qui a fait toutes les
provinces à abolir sac là il semble
s'attaquer donc surtout aux tests de
radiologie au fait qu'ils sont que les
scans des résonances qui sont faites
rares de l'hôpital en termes en
considération comme et à des services
heureux qui donc devraient être couverts
par l'assurance maladie j'ai trouvé la
réponse de la ministre mais quand un peu
curieuse parce que le dis on va pas
fermer des portes d'accès mais en fait
c'est un peu l'inversé
il s'agit d'ouvrir l'accès à en couvrant
publiquement l'assurance comme ça a été
fait avec l'échographie donc lounis
barrette a fait ça l'an dernier
maintenant l'échographie est accessible
autant à l'hôpital qu'à l'extérieur de
l'hôpital et ses couverts
donc c'est plus ouvrir des portes j'ai
trouvé un pull à la rhétorique un peu un
peu curieuse un batelier scott avoir
raison de faire ça ben ça veut qu'ottawa
se pose comme défenseur comme il le fait
dans le passé depuis 30 ans des cinq
conditions donc l'accessibilité puis
quand il ya des tarifs faisait sans
problèmes d'accessibilité des gens qui
ont tout simplement pas les moyens de se
payer des scans dans le privé il faut il
faut raisonner autrement tout en
protégeant ce qui se passe dans public
puis l'offre de services dans le public
ça c'est fondamental et en terminant
médecins spécialistes vous avez déjà a
proposé de geler le salaire des médecins
l'ont on apprend que l'étude comparative
entre le québec et l'ontario on va la
connaître en janvier prochain ce que
vous venez qu'on doit geler les tarifs
des vols
je pense qu'il faut il ya eu un objectif
sur l'étude on va voir ce qui va sortir
de ça mais je pense que les médecins en
particulier mais ces spécialistes dont
je suis gagnent très bien leur vie et je
pense que je lui ai toujours dit il y
aurait d'autres endroits où on pourrait
investir ces sommes là actuellement puis
je pense que c'est juste une position
raisonnable sur la question donc la
position de la personne du québec du
gouvernement le goût de vouloir rouvrir
cette entente là et si c'est possible
parce que l'on sait plus trop finalement
s'ils ont valu au bout de la faire et
vous êtes en faveur des sabres mais la
question c'est qu'est-ce que ça réplique
parce que c'est ce que c'est les
nouveaux services aux patients et que si
on veut on n'a fait que la de l'entente
pourrait affecter ces services là ça
c'est une chose mais on peut jouer sur
le tarif on peut jouer sur plein de
choses je pense que des approches que
tout le monde peut trouver raisonnable
des deux côtés qu'on peut faire dans ce
sens très bien bon biens d'occasion car
on peut voir aujourd'hui au salon de la
journée l'après midi puis demain
également et demain
également des prescriptions littéraire
d'ailleurs à midi une excellente à ce
big s'est rangé aux chirurgiens
effectivement prête à côte
merci beaucoup a précisé m